Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfshark VPN más sobre esto En un
momento
[Música]
la antártida ubicada en el área más
austral del planeta tierra es un
gigantesco desierto de hielo de 13,66
millones de kilómetros cuadrados para
que os hagáis una idea esto supone que
es un 35% más grande que todo el
continente europeo hablamos de la última
región en ser descubierta y colonizada
por el ser humano y aunque hoy en día en
plena era de la información tenemos todo
tipo de datos al alcance de la mano Es
cierto que más allá del hielo las focas
y los pingüinos es muy poco lo que en
general se sabe del Gran continente
blanco y ojo porque esta región fría
seca Ventosa Y despoblada contiene
aproximadamente el 90% del hielo de la
tierra y con ello el 70% de todo el agua
dulce y por supuesto no hablamos solo de
agua también de muchos otros recursos
naturales Así que a pesar de que la
antártida no cuenta con una población
originaria Como por ejemplo si la tiene
el Ártico arrastra varias décadas de
importantes controversias e intereses
políticos y militares que pueden
terminar provocando serias disputas en
un futuro no tan lejano Así que la
pregunta es cerca de adentrarnos en la
era de los conflictos antárticos quién
aspira a controlar este vasto territorio
y que pretende con ello qué riquezas
ocultas se esconden detrás de toda esta
historia y antes de ir con las
respuestas otra pregunta importante eres
de los que te conectas a wifis públicas
o te gusta siempre Buscar el mejor
precio pues atento porque surfshark es
para ti si eres fan de las cafeterías
los viajes o llevas una vida nómada te
mantendrás al boe Incluso en redes wi-fi
públicas cifrando tus datos en línea y
manteniéndote a salvo de hecho el tema
de la ciberseguridad es algo que se
toman muy pero que muy en serio es la
primera VPN comercial que puede presumir
de tener servidores en más de 100 países
distintos Y sabías que muchas webs te
muestran precios Según tu ubicación o tu
dispositivo pues encendiendo tu VPN de
surfshark conseguirás las mejores
ofertas al comprar por ejemplo tu
próximo billete de avión pero por si
todo esto fuera poco con una misma
cuenta Ahora vas a poder registrar todos
los dispositivos que quieras sin límite
tu teléfono la tablet la Smart TV y el
portátil etcétera etcétera y esperad
porque ahora viene lo mejor de todo
ahora mismo usando el código politik
acabado en k disfrutar de un 83% de
descuento y 3 meses gratis así que ya lo
sabéis pero dicho esto continuemos con
la Antártida
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas la antártida es
un desierto de hielo escasamente
habitado pero que sin embargo ha
despertado un gran interés entre
científicos y exploradores desde hace ya
varios siglos poco a poco las diferentes
expediciones han ido incrementando
nuestro conocimiento sobre la zona lo
que automáticamente despertó también la
ambición de muchos países para controlar
el territorio en la actualidad por
ejemplo son siete los países que
reclaman tener derechos de soberanía
sobre parte de la Antártida lo que ha
creado todo un Enjambre legal y político
cuyo fondo permanece sin resolverse Pero
la pregunta es Quiénes son estos países
y que persiguen exactamente por qué
tanto interés por un territorio helado
Pues bien Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
pero antes antes Esta es una de esas
ocasiones en las que tenemos que empezar
viendo un poco de historia atentos
[Música]
de la ciencia a la ambición política
desde al menos el siglo XV podemos
encontrar en diversos mapas un área
continental denominada Terra australis
un área cuyos detalles eran
completamente desconocidos y que se
ubicaba sistemáticamente al sur del
estrecho de Magallanes es decir al sur
de Sudamérica Esta última región de
hecho fue la primera en tener un
contacto político territorial relevante
con este territorio virgen incluso ya en
1539 la corona española nombró a Pedro
Sancho de la hoz como gobernador de la
Terra australis esta fue la primera vez
que una potencia pues tuvo la pretensión
de apropiarse y gobernar la zona al
menos sobre el papel Porque lo cierto Es
que esto no se tradujo en la
construcción de bases ni en intentos de
ocupar permanentemente el territorio de
hecho el área continuó sin despertar
mucho interés hasta que a finales del
siglo XIX y hasta principios de la
década de los años 20 se produjo la
conocida como edad heroica de la
exploración antártica
en 1898 una expedición liderada por el
belga Adrián guerras de gomery y
compuesta fundamentalmente por
científicos y explora polacos rumanos y
noruegos se convirtió en el primer
contingente humano en pasar un invierno
en este continente helado a partir de
entonces Y hasta la Primera Guerra
Mundial se pusieron en marcha 16
expediciones de ocho países diferentes
todas ellas con banderas compartidas
entre diferentes nacionalidades
sin embargo la historia de un vuelco
hacia 1903 cuando la expedición
antártica nacional escocesa y estableció
un observatorio meteorológico en las
islas orcadas del sur lo hizo después de
que su barco quedará aprisionado por los
hielos del mar Antártico Y sabéis que
cuando lograron volver a navegar se
dirigieron a Buenos Aires para
aprovisionarse pero allí cambiaron de
planes le ofrecieron al gobierno
argentino la venta de la instalación la
base el instrumental y los aparatos de
observación el entonces presidente Julio
argentino roca aceptó por decreto el
ofrecimiento y autorizó a la oficina
meteorológica Argentina a hacerse cargo
de la estación que desde ese preciso
momento pasaría a conocerse como base
orcadas años después diferentes países
fueron Asimismo desplegando bases en la
zona sumando nuevas reclamaciones
territoriales hasta crear un enorme
jaleo de paralelos y latitudes que
muchas ocasiones tal y como veremos se
llega a superponer Así que dicho esto
Ahora la pregunta es muy clara quién
demonios controla la antártida Pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
tierra de todos o de nadie
la situación política de la Antártida
resultaba muy particular digamos que es
única en todo el mundo ha formado una
especie de condominio donde algunos
países reclaman una porción de soberanía
al tiempo que otros sin aparentes
pretensiones territoriales mantienen
bases permanentes o temporales de
investigación científica por lo general
son las naciones más cercanas a la
antártida las que más empeño tienen en
extender su soberanía en la zona aquí el
concepto de proximidad territorial pues
juega un papel clave en concreto esta
que veis en pantalla es una lista con
los países que mantienen alguna
reclamación territorial sobre este
territorio y luego tenemos otros tantos
con bases permanentes entre ellos por
supuesto Estados Unidos Rusia y China
por citar solo algunos ejemplos y ojo
porque en total se estima que son ya más
de 70 las bases permanentes que podemos
encontrar en este territorio
[Música]
de esta lista Francia y Noruega
justifican sus reclamaciones en base a
los descubrimientos que misiones con su
bandera hicieron en la Antártida Nueva
Zelanda y Australia al ser naciones
australes justifican cierta cercanía
geográfica sin embargo todo se pone
mucho más interesante y complejo cuando
echamos un vistazo a la situación de
Reino Unido chile y Argentina como
podéis ver estos tres países tienen
reclamaciones de soberanía sobre
territorios superpuestos es decir los
británicos reclaman casi la misma
porción de tierra que chile y Argentina
Eso sí en cierta forma todo este cabo de
soberanías y todas las misiones
científicas y están en cierta forma
organizadas por la comunidad
internacional y es que veréis en 1959 12
países firmaron en Washington el tratado
Antártico un acuerdo que engloba a 54 en
este documento se establecieron Cuáles
serían las bases fundamentales para
gestionar la zona la idea era reducir
cualquier posibilidad de que la
antártida terminara provocando un
conflicto gran escala básicamente estos
son los tres puntos claves del acuerdo
que hoy dictan cómo se gestiona la
antártida son los límites legales en
este territorio fijaos
y eso no es todo este tratado se ha ido
reforzando con el paso del tiempo y
desde la firma del conocido como
protocolo de Madrid de 1991 también se
prohíbe expresamente la explotación
comercial de los recursos mineros que se
puedan encontrar la idea es que la
antártida se convierta en una reserva
científica y natural con carácter
internacional y de hecho desde 1961 se
celebra periódicamente la reunión
consultiva del tratado Antártico una
especie de foro para tomar decisiones
sobre el lugar
Además desde el año 2003 también
funciona en Buenos Aires la secretaría
del tratado Antártico un órgano
ejecutivo encargado de facilitar el
intercambio de información entre las
partes del tratado y promover los
protocolos medioambientales que tienen
que respetarse las incursiones que se
hacen en la zona sería algo así para
entendernos como una especie de gobierno
Antártico y así es queridos amigos como
este continente lado funciona como una
especie de tierra de todos y de nadie al
mismo tiempo pero vale vale Ya sé lo que
estáis pensando Enrique Entonces por qué
demonios habláis de ellos visualpolitik
no sé no parece mucho más que un parque
natural protegido pues la cuestión es
que no todo es de color de rosas
empezando porque chile Argentina y Reino
Unido comparten Prácticamente la misma
reclamación territorial Y decidme si os
ocurre algún ingrediente mejor para el
conflicto pues atentos
una nueva guerra fría antártica
trato de Antártico sistema del tratado
secretaría del tratado sí De momento
todo parece muy bien armado y diseñado
para que la antártida sea una zona de
cooperación y convivencia mutua Pero
esto no siempre ha sido así
entre 1946 y 1947 Estados Unidos impulsó
la operación la cual consistía en el
despliegue de 13 barcos
4.700 hombres y numerosos aeronaves en
una incursión antártica el objetivo era
llevar a cabo maniobras y ejercicios
para entrenar al personal y probar el
material bélico en condiciones de frío
extremo pensando Claro está en un
potencial conflicto con la entonces
Unión soviética
[Música]
años más tarde en febrero de 1952 tuvo
lugar el incidente de la Bahía esperanza
en este caso uniformados argentinos
desplegados en un destacamento naval al
norte de la Antártida emitieron disparos
de advertencia a militares británicos
que se encontraban desembarcando
materiales frente al área manejada por
la Argentina
[Música]
luego apenas un año después en 1953 Se
repitió un episodio similar con el
incidente de La Isla decepción cinco
Royal Marín británicos desembarcaron y
apresaron a dos marinos argentinos como
respuesta a la construcción de un
refugio argentino en la zona
En otras palabras que la cosa se estaba
poniendo cada vez más y más tensa eso sí
la firma del tratado Antártico mejoró
considerablemente la estabilidad de la
zona Pero entonces entonces la guerra de
las malvinas agitó de nuevo este asunto
ya que el despliegue territorial que
Londres sostiene sobre el continente
lado tiene base Precisamente en la
capital de las malvinas es decir que la
presencia del Reino Unido de la
Antártida depende de las malvinas por lo
que el enfrentamiento con la Argentina
afecte automáticamente al continente
blanco digamos que Buenos Aires
considera que la propia reclamación
británica sobre la antártida es una
especie de acto colonial cuyo origen
está Precisamente en la no
descolonización de las malvinas es al
menos es la posición Argentina Claro que
quizás con el paso del tiempo el
enfrentamiento que más puede llegar a
desarrollarse es precisamente el que
afecta a los dos países sudamericanos
presentes en toda esta historia chile y
la Argentina
sin ninguna confianza
es algo relativamente poco conocido pero
en 1977 chile y Argentina estuvieron al
borde de entrada en guerra por el canal
beagle un paso marítimo que conecta el
Océano Atlántico con el océano Pacífico
y que es reclamado por ambos países y es
que veréis ese año la junta militar
Argentina Pues decidió hacer caso omiso
de un lado arbitral británico que
establecía los límites de la zona en su
lugar movilizó a las fuerzas armadas el
propio Juan Pablo II tuvo que intervenir
para persuadir tanto a Videla como a
pinochet de que el uso de la fuerza no
era una alternativa Y aunque hoy esa
posibilidad parezca totalmente
descabellada Lo cierto es que Buenos
Aires Santiago y Londres protagonizan un
trío de tensión constante en el extremo
astral de América del Sur hubo un
enfrentamiento político y diplomático
que los últimos años nos ha dejado
capítulos como esto octubre de 2007
Argentina lista para desafiar los
reclamos antárticos de Gran Bretaña el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
Argentina advirtió que su país
solicitará la soberanía sobre el fondo
del océano alrededor de las Islas
malvinas y la antártida diciembre de
2012 Argentina enojada por territorio
Antártico que lleva el nombre de la
reina septiembre de 2021 Argentina y
chile chocan por una disputa marítima en
el extremo suramericano el gobierno de
Buenos Aires acusa a su para andino de
apropiarse de 5.500 kilómetros cuadrados
de su plataforma Marina en una de las
zonas más australes del planeta octubre
de 2022 generó malestar en Chile la
visita de tres ministros argentinos a la
antártida la tensión se produce luego
del fortalecimiento de los controles de
vigilancia en el Atlántico Sur por parte
del gobierno argentino mediante la
creación del Comando conjunto marítimo a
ver Esto es Quizás lo más importante de
toda esta historia más allá de la pura
política los tres países colaboran en
materia de rescates o de investigaciones
científicas es decir que las cosas
fluyen razonablemente bien pero qué
pasaría si el continente blanco dejara
de ser tan aburrido
[Música]
porque veámoslo de otra forma la
antártida es un continente inmenso
cubierto de hielo pero debajo de ese
hielo queridos amigos puede haber muchas
cosas y también en el fondo del océano
de entrada la antártida es la mayor
reserva de agua dulce de todo el planeta
hablamos del 70% de todas las reservas
mundiales además sus cielos están casi
totalmente libres de interferencias de
radio Por lo que son potencialmente
ideales para la investigación del
espacio profundo y el seguimiento
satelital y por tanto para operaciones
de vigilancia espionaje y control del
armamento por control remoto además por
si esto fuera poco un estudio de
servicio geológico de Estados Unidos del
92 concluyó que podrían existir grandes
cantidades de petróleo y de gas natural
en una primera aproximación muy
incipiente se apuntaba a más de 19.000
millones de barriles de crudo y 106
trillones de pies cúbicos de gas es
decir que si esas son las primeras
indagaciones la realidad podría ser
mucho más lucrativa y de hecho los
últimos años algunas estimaciones
apuntan a que podríamos estar hablando
agarrados a la silla de más de 200.000
millones de barriles es decir que la
antártida podría contener las reservas
de petróleo más grandes de todo el
planeta
[Música]
y Exactamente lo mismo ocurre con otros
muchos minerales la antártida puede ser
una enorme fuente de recursos
completamente virgen y abierta para el
primero que pase por allí Por supuesto
el tratado Atlántico que antes hemos
visto prohíbe la explotación comercial
de los recursos naturales en esta zona
del mundo pero algunos creen que solo lo
hace hasta el año 2048 hay debate al
respecto sea como sea hoy por hoy los
costes de extracción serían
disparatadamente altos sin ir más lejos
por la enorme capa de hielo que cubre el
continente pero podría cambiar esto en
el futuro sobre la tecnología creo que
caben pocas dudas la política ya es otra
cosa pero el 2048 no está lejos tendrá
esta noticia algo que ver con todo esto
el régimen chino aumenta la presión para
construir una base naval estratégica en
tierra del fuego china quiere que el sur
argentino sea su puerta de entrada a la
antártida seguro que en un futuro de una
forma u otra este continente blanco nos
dará mucho de que hablar pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti sabías que
tantos países reclaman su soberanía
sobre la antártida Cuál crees que será
el rol de Argentina chile y Reino Unido
en la región crees que pueden futuros
conflictos políticos económicos e
incluso militares déjanos por aquí abajo
vuestros comentarios y hablamos debate
Ah importante recordad que con el código
politica acabado en K podréis disfrutar
de un 83% de descuento y 3 meses gratis
en surfshark el link como siempre en la
descripción y ahora si este vídeo ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros a visualpolitik una
vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]